ROARS, DEFENSE OFFICIALS SAY
THIS COULD HINT AT GROWING
MORALE PROBLEMS INSIDE VLADIMIR
PUTIN'S ARMED FORCES.
>> Reporter: WITH RUSSIA'S WAR
IN UKRAINE STALLED, CNN HAS
LEARNED OF A RARE MEETING IN
MOSCOW BETWEEN U.S. AND RUSSIAN
MILITARY OFFICIALS WHICH
ACCORDING TO A U.S. READOUT OF
THE MEETING CONTAINED A, QUOTE,
REVEALING MOMENT FROM RUSSIAN
MAJOR GENERAL EVGENY VILYIN.
AN ATTACHE CASUALLY WORKED ABOUT
HIS FAMILY IN UKRAINE.
ACCORDING TO THE READOUT, THE
GENERAL'S STOIC DEMEANOR
SUDDENLY BECAME FLUSHED AND
AGITATED.
ILYIN REPLIED HE WAS BORN IN
UKRAINE AND WENT TO SCHOOL IN
DONETSK, AND THEN SAID ACCORDING
TO THE READOUT, THE SITUATION IN
UKRAINE IS TRAGIC, AND I AM VERY
DEPRESSED OVER IT.
BEFORE WALKING OUT WITHOUT
SHAKING HANDS.
THE ATTACHE WROTE IN THE READOUT
THE FIRE IN HIS EYES AND
FLUSTERED DEMEANOR LEFT A CHILL
DOWN THE SPINE.
MEETINGS WITH RUSSIAN OFFICIALS
ARE TYPICALLY SCRIPTED, BUT THE
TWO ATTACHES SAID THEY HAD NEVER
WITNESSED SUCH AN OUTBURST BY
RUSSIAN COUNTERPARTS AT AN
OFFICIAL MEETING.
THE READOUT BY THE OFFICIALS
CONCLUDES, AT THE VERY LEAST, IT
IS CLEAR THAT MORALE PROBLEMS
AMONG RUSSIAN FORCES ARE NOT
LIMITED TO FRONTLINE TROOPS.
THE READOUT DESCRIBES ONLY THE
IMPRESSIONS OF THE U.S.
OFFICIALS AND DOES NOT
DEFINITIVELY EXPLAIN ILYIN'S
BEHAVIOR.
SUCH READOUTS ARE TYPICALLY TOO
SENSITIVE TO BE MADE PUBLIC.
>> READOUTS OF THIS TYPE ARE
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEY GIVE US
AN INSIGHT, A POTENTIAL INSIGHT
INTO WHAT THE RUSSIANS ARE
REALLY THINKING.
BUT IT ALSO SHOWS THAT THERE IS
SOME KIND OF A MORALE PROBLEM
WITHIN THE RUSSIAN HIERARCHY,
AND IT EXTENDS POSSIBLY ALL THE
WAY UP TO THE TOP.
>> Reporter: THE RUSSIAN
MINISTRY OF DEFENSE DID NOT
RESPOND TO A CNN REQUEST FOR
COMMENT ON THE MEETING OR THE
READOUT.
BUT THE KREMLIN HAS DENIED
REPORTS OF LOW MORALE AMONG ITS
FORCES IN UKRAINE.
>> YOU WOULD PROBABLY HAVE TO
DOUBT THIS INFORMATION.
YOU HAVE TO DOUBT IT AND YOU
HAVE TO THINK TWICE, WHETHER IT
IS TRUE OR NOT.
>> Reporter: AS RUSSIA FACES
STIFF RESISTANCE FROM UKRAINIAN
FORCES, IF THE AMERICANS ARE
CORRECT AND MORALE IS AN ISSUE,
IT'S A CHALLENGE THE RUSSIANS
CAN ILL AFFORD.
>> WE'VE SEEN INCREASING
INDICATIONS THAT MORALE AND UNIT
COHESION IS A PROBLEM.
AND, YES, THAT ABSOLUTELY
TRANSLATES INTO POTENTIAL
MILITARY EFFECTIVENESS ISSUES.
>> Reporter: A RUSSIAN GENERAL
FLUSHED AND AGITATED ACCORDING
TO THE AMERICANS.
JUST ONE MORE MYSTERY ABOUT WHAT
REALLY MAY BE GOING ON BEHIND
KREMLIN WALLS.
BARBARA STARR, CNN, THE
PENTAGON.
>> INTERESTING.
NINA DOS SANTOS JOINS ME FROM
LONDON WITH MORE ON THE MORALE,
AND ALSO ON SOME HIGH LEVEL
DEPARTURES FROM THE RUSSIAN
CIRCLES OF POWER.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THERE HAS BEEN SOME HIGH LEVEL
DEPARTURES OVERSEAS.
THERE WAS ANATOLY CHUBAIS.
HE WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR AN
ENVIRONMENTAL BRIEF.
BUT THERE HAS ALSO BEEN QUESTION
MARKS OVER THE FUTURE OF MANY
MEMBERS OF THE MILITARY AS WELL,
WITH THE REPORTS ONE OF THEM
MIGHT BE UNDER HOUSE ARREST.
THERE IS LOTS OF SPECULATION
ABOUT THE WHEREABOUTS OF SERGEI
SHOIBU WHO HASN'T BEEN SEEN IN
ABOUT 12 DAYS NOW.
AS OF COURSE THIS RISING NUMBER
OF CASUALTIES APPEARS TO GROW BY
THE DAY FOR RUSSIA AND JUST
GOING INTO THE NUMBERS HERE,
NATO HAS BEEN SAYING THEY
ESTIMATE THE NUMBER OF 40,000
RUSSIAN TROOPS ARE EITHER DEAD,
WOUNDED OR MISSING IN ACTION OR
HAVE BEEN CAPTURED IN UKRAINE.
UKRAINE ITSELF ESTIMATES THE
CASUALTIES AMONG RUSSIAN
SOLDIERS COULD BE AS HIGH AS
OVER 15,000.
AND RUSSIA ITSELF JUST
INTERESTING ENOUGH, HALA, LAST
WEEK I'M SURE YOU REMEMBER MAY
HAVE ACCIDENTALLY REVEALED
CASUALTY NUMBERS THEMSELVES WHEN
ONE OF THE STATE NEWS COMPANIES
ACCIDENTALLY PUT OUT A REPORT
SAYING THE DEFENSE MINISTRY
CONCERNED THAT THERE ARE ALMOST
10,000 RUSSIAN SOLDIERS WHO HAVE
LOST THEIR LIVES.
THAT WAS QUICKLY RETRACTED.
SO FAR THE OFFICIAL ESTIMATE
HASN'T BEEN REALLY UPDATED FOR A
COUPLE OF WEEKS FROM RUSSIA WHEN
IT SAID THAT THERE WERE HUNDREDS
OF SOLDIERS WHO HAD LOST THEIR
LIVES IN WHAT IT CALLS,
CONTINUES TO CALL A SPECIAL
MILITARY OPERATION IN UKRAINE
THAT THE REST TELEPHONE WORLD
CALLS AN INVASION.
AND WHAT'S ALSO IMPORTANT WHEN
IT COMES TO MORALE IS THE
COMMAND STRUCTURE OF THE RUSSIAN
MILITARY, WHICH IS KNOWN FOR
BEING NOTORIOUSLY HIERARCHICALH.
IT MEANS IT BRINGS MORE SENIOR
GENERALS TO THE FRONT OF THE
ACTION IN COMBAT ZONES LIKE
UKRAINE, AND THAT IS WHERE WE'VE
ALSO SEEN A NUMBER OF LOSSES.
ABOUT SEVERAL RUSSIAN GENERALS
HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES SO FAR IN
UKRAINE.
AND THEN SCORES OF OTHER
COLONELS AND OTHER OFFICERS AS
WELL.
SO ALL OF THIS CONTRIBUTING TO
QUESTION MARKS OVER MORALE.
THERE HAS BEEN REPORTS ABOUT
RUSSIAN SOLDIERS SUFFERING FROM
FROSTBITE BECAUSE THEIR MILITARY
KIT ISN'T AS GOOD AS THE
UKRAINIAN DEFENDING SOLDIERS'
MILITARY KIT.
MANY OF THEM REPORTEDLY HUNGRY
WHEN THEY HAVE BEEN CAPTURE
BESIDE I UKRAINIAN SOLDIERS.
AND THEN THE BIG QUESTION MARK
IS THE FATE OF THEIR DEFENSE
MINISTER, SERGEI SHOIGU WHO
HASN'T BEEN SEEN FOR ABOUT 12
DAYS, NOW 13.
HA